Let's look at a more complicated case of powers of powers. Here, I don't just
have one base, I have two I'm multiplying 4 cubed and 3 squared. And this
quantity will be raised to the 4th power. If I want to simplify this problem and
in particular the exponents, I would need to rewrite this. First, I write 4
cubed times 3 squared four times, that would be this. Notice that I have
multiplication between every single term, so this is really just a product of
factors, and I don't need to list the parenthesis. We can rearrange the product
of our factors and I can group the 4 cubes together and the 3 squared's
together. If I expanded all this out I would have 12 4s and 8 3s. So I know my
final answer is 4 to the 12th times 3 to the 8th. So I know my final answer
would be 4 to the 12th and 3 to the 8th. Again, I don't want to have to list all
these factors out when I'm doing this work. There must be a shorter way. If I
look at how these exponents changed, what did I really do? Well it turns out
that I distributed this exponent of four to each of the factors 4 cubed and 3
squared. So I have 4 to the 3rd raised to the 4th power and 3 squared raised to
the 4th power. Now we just apply the rule that we learned before. When we raise
a power to a power, we multiply the exponents together. So I get 4 to the 12th
and 3 to the 8th. Pretty neat.